this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by audible get your first
audiobook for free at audible.com
real engineering
[Music]
an extensive program of research and
development in the field of disk flight
which was started in 1952
is being conducted by avro aircraft
limited at malton ontario
early studies on behalf of the united
states air force proved the feasibility
of a circular platform vertical takeoff
aircraft utilizing a system of
peripheral jets for propulsion
stabilization and control
[Music]
what you are witnessing is one of the
most bizarre technologies of the mid
20th century the year was 1960. the cold
war was looming over america and within
five years american troops will be
entering vietnam many of them by
helicopter the helicopter's role was
clear a vertical take-off vehicle
capable of rapidly deploying behind
enemy lines with no need for runways it
could carry both men and weapons and
serve a multitude of roles but its speed
and maneuverability left it vulnerable
to attack and it could not intercept
enemy planes
the avrocar was envisioned as a solution
a new type of airframe that could
fulfill both the role of a helicopter
and a supersonic jet fighter and it all
began life as project 1794 with the goal
of creating a vertical takeoff and
landing aircraft capable of flying at
three times the speed of sound with a
service ceiling of 100 000 feet
this all sounds like it was born from
the imagination of alien conspiracy
theorists but the design was perfectly
logical in the mind of john frost a
renowned and respected design engineer
john's concept for the avro car was
seeded from his experimentation with
combining two physical phenomena the
koanda effect and ground effect
the koanda effect is simply the tendency
of a fluid to follow the curve of a
convex shape modern planes like the c-17
take advantage of the effect with flaps
which can descend into the exhaust flow
of the engines during landings this
would redirect some of the exhaust
downwards to provide additional lift
allowing the c-17 to slow its approach
speed and land on shorter runways
most online publications on this vehicle
overstate the importance of the cowanda
effect and in some cases completely
confuse it for ground effect while there
are many test videos of john frost
experimenting with the effect with small
prototypes the effect does not get a
single mention in the initial secret
white paper where early designs were
presented
there were multiple concepts drawn up
for the avrocar but they all centered
around one basic idea direct high
pressure air 360 degrees outwards and
use shutters and control surfaces to
redirect it for control the koanda
effect was not a feature of these kind
of devices the initial blue sky design
called for a completely novel engine
layout which would not use conventional
jet engines for power instead there
would be one large diameter engine
surrounding the pilot with the
compressor stage mounted on the inner
diameter the turbine mounted on the
outer diameter with a combustion chamber
in between a major change from typical
jet engines which have these stages
mounted sequentially over a common axle
this new engine would have been an ideal
use of space with fuel tanks mounted in
a ring around the pilot which presented
a massive fire hazard but kept the
center of gravity as close to the center
of pressure as possible
however designing an entirely novel
engine for the prototype would have been
far too costly so a compromised design
was created for the early prototype
designs
commercially available turbojets would
be mounted radially around the disk in a
repeating pattern this created a
radially symmetric design that would
allow for repeating sections identical
in construction this was a huge
advantage for the flying disc design as
it would reduce the number of parts
needed thanks to the rayleigh symmetric
design resulting in repeating parts this
would drastically reduce manufacturing
costs
these turbojet engines would be mounted
around a central turbine the outlet
pressure of these turbojets would drive
this turbine in the middle section and
its remaining kinetic energy would be
used to provide lift by exhausting it
directly downwards
meanwhile the rotation of this turbine
was powering two impeller levels mounted
above and below the turbine these
centrifugal impellers would draw air
from intakes above and below the disk
and accelerate it radially outwards
through docks
some of this air would be redirected
into the inlet of the turbojet engines
to maintain a constant ram pressure
which is the pressure we typically
associate at the inlet of a jet engine
as an aircraft forces itself through the
air for this design i don't see much of
the coanda effect being used as the air
has no other option then to exhaust in
the direction the shutters allow them to
this was the general concept behind the
avrocare but the two prototypes that
were actually built were much lower in
spec with three turbojet engines instead
of six
here they were mounted tangentially
rather than perpendicularly to the inner
turbine which would drive the inner
turbo rotor which would work similarly
to the f35s direct lift rotor by
directing some of this air directly
downwards however it differs from the
f-35 as some of that air was expelled
outwards too
for these prototypes the cowanda effect
may have played a larger role as some of
the air was directed over the outer
surface of the aircraft however this
prototype was underpowered with a huge
amount of energy being lost through
friction drag in the ducting system and
through powering the turbo rotor using a
geared drive system similar to the f-35
would result in far less friction and
energy loss
this prototype relied completely on the
lift boosting effects of ground effect
to achieve liftoff ground effect is
simply a boost in lift when an aircraft
is close enough to the ground to create
a high pressure cushion of air between
the vehicle and the ground but this
created some issues for the prototype
here you can see john frost perhaps
unintentionally demonstrating the first
with his early tests he lifts the small
prototype out of the ground effect zone
where it no longer has enough lift to
keep itself aloft and then let's go
allowing the scale model to drop back
into the ground effect zone where the
high pressure air acts like a bouncy
castle the model begins to bob up and
down until the motion has finally been
dampened out
this bopping motion can be an annoyance
but a far larger issue was an
aerodynamic instability the designers of
the avrocar dubbed hubcapping that it
could cause
this was named after the motion a hubcap
or any circular shape would make as it
rotated around its rim you can see the
pilots of the avrocar struggling to
control the vehicle in most of the
archival footage of its testing they
likened it to trying to balance on a
beach ball a constant physically and
demanding task
this was again caused by how ground
effect interacted with the aircraft at
various altitudes ground effect means
that lift rises the closer to the ground
you air but this causes issues with
aerodynamic instability when the avrocar
was tilted here the right side of the
vehicle comes closer to the ground and
the left side moves further away this
causes the center of pressure to shift
to the right as the lift shifts to the
right this however did not act as a
restoring force to keep the avrocar
level as the vehicle needed to keep its
nose down in order to move forward which
shifted its center of weight forward
instead it resulted in the avrocar
swinging around its pitch and roll axis
in that hubcapping motion
over the next year the team worked on
fixing this issue the turbofan itself
was intended to provide stabilization
the turbofan would desire to remain in a
horizontal position through gyroscopic
action so the engineers developed a
system where they could couple this
action to the controls at the outer rim
of the aircraft they did this by
mounting the turbo fan to a gimbal
allowing the avrocar to freely rotate
around the turbo fan if the avrocar
deviated from this horizontal position
it would cause linkages connected to the
gimbal system to move and shift the
control surfaces to correct the tilt as
clever as this system was before the age
of fly-by-wire technology it could not
compensate for the inherent instability
of the aircraft
the prototype was modified over the
testing period with different control
mechanisms but none of them could solve
this instability problem the gyroscopic
effects were having negative effects
elsewhere too the afro car took five
seconds to rotate 90 degrees
counterclockwise which is too long to
begin with but it took over twice as
long at 11 seconds to turn clockwise
against the rotation of the turbo roader
john frost attempted to address some of
the problems in 1961 designing this
variation of the avrocar which included
a wing and a tail to provide lateral and
pitch stability while moving the cockpit
to the front of the vehicle ultimately
it was too late the design was ditched
as it was simply converging into a plane
with fetal capabilities which were in
research at that time like the harrier
jump jet which would fly its first
flight in 1967 and enter service in
1969. today we can see aspects of its
design being used in the f-35 with the
turbo router while the instability
issues with hovering in ground effect
are barely an issue for this aircraft
with advanced computer control reacting
to wobbles before the pilot has even
time to notice them who knows if the
design was revisited today the flying
saucer could truly exit the realm of
science fiction after all most of
science fiction is based on true science
potential we can learn a lot about
science through exploration of
hypotheticals in audiobooks like we are
legion we are bob easily one of the most
enjoyable science fiction series i have
ever listened to on audible we are
legion we are bob explorers what
artificial intelligence combined with
von neumann probes or self-replicating
spacecraft would look like this book
tells the story of a young software
engineer who dies and finds his
personality has been uploaded to a space
probe destined to explore the universe
and battle with space probes from
competing nations the book is amazingly
funny as we witness a man trying to keep
himself entertained with only ever
stranger versions of himself to keep him
company easily one of the most
entertaining and informative audiobooks
i listened to last year you can listen
to this title for free if you visit
audible.com
real engineering or text real
engineering to 500 500 this will get you
a 30-day audible trial with access to
one audio book and two audible originals
included after that you will get one
free audio book every month as part of
your subscription which you could use
for the next two audio books in the we
are legion trilogy in fact audible is
currently offering an amazing deal if
you finish three audio books by march
3rd you'll get a 20 amazon gift card for
free so just listen to this amazing
series and get paid 20 for the pleasure
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters if
you'd like to see more from me the links
to my instagram twitter subreddit and
discord server are below